NASIR KHAN: Once again,
we are bringing you
a developer preview release of
the next version of Android.
So you can test your apps,
explore new features,
and provide feedback
to our team.
Hi, my name is Nasir Khan,
and I'm a developer advocate
with Android.
Android O has more
control over what
applications in the background
can do as part of an effort
to improve interactive
performance by improving
RAM usage.
Android Nougat prevented
apps from receiving
three specific
implicit broadcasts,
such as the new photo broadcast
from manifest-declared
receivers.
Apps targeting O will no longer
receive implicit broadcasts
to most manifest-declared
receivers.
There are a few exceptions
that will still be allowed,
such as BOOT_COMPLETED,
LOCALE_CHANGED, et cetera.
Explicit broadcasts that target
the application package that
are registered in the
manifest will still
be received, like
ACTION_MY_PACKAGE_REPLACED.
And you can still register to
receive implicit broadcasts
while you have it active.
On apps targeting Android
O, background services
now only run for a short
time after the app no longer
has visible activity or
a foreground service.
startService, or
service PendingIntent
will throw an
IllegalStateException
when the app is not
in the foreground.
Foreground services that require
a persistent notification
work as usual.
And there's a new API to start
a foreground service directly,
startServiceInForeground.
Finally, even if your
app doesn't target O,
there will be a few changes.
First, when your app
enters the cached state--
that is, with no active
Android component--
any wake lock it holds will
be automatically released.
Second, location
updates will change.
Apps that request
background location updates
will only get limited
updates a few times per hour.
Foreground services
aren't impacted.
So apps that do navigation
or track fitness
can continue to
get faster updates
while they are performing
their location-dependent tasks.
If another app is using
location in the foreground,
then your background app
can get location updates
at the same frequency
as that foreground app.
We are constantly working
to improve user privacy.
So even if you
don't target O, you
will notice a change with
Android ID in Settings.Secure.
In O, it will return a different
identifier for different apps.
In other words, it is now
scoped per app, per user.
This new value will persist
across app reinstalls.
But for a simple, standard
system to help monetize app,
use user-resettable
Advertising ID instead,
provided by Google
Play Services.
Also considering
privacy, apps targeting O
won't be able to get access
to user accounts using
GET_ACCOUNTS permissions alone.
Instead apps must rely on the
account choosing activity.
Account owners can now choose
whether the accounts will
be visible to other apps, and
the account choosing activity
will be updated accordingly.
Android O adds
notification channels
to give you those more
fine-grained control
of notifications and app
developers more flexibility
to send different
types of notifications
with less risk of being
completely blocked.
A notification channel is a
named category of notification
from a single app.
Users can block a
single category,
or alter its behavior, such
as changing buttons, adding
vibration and lights, and
altering the lock screen
privacy.
You can use channels to
have different categories
of notification.
For example, a chat app
may show two different chat
conversations.
End user may be able to apply
different settings to them.
A long press on Notification
[? brings ?] the channel
settings.
All apps targeting O
must implement channels.
Otherwise, the notification
will not show up.
It's super easy to do.
Just create a
channel, and then call
said channel within the
notification builder.
There is much more in
[? user notifications ?]
like ability to snooze,
set timeouts to cancel,
background colors of
notification display.
Make sure to check
out the details.
Filling out forms is a
time-consuming and error-prone
task.
The new autofill framework
makes it easy for apps
to help their
users through this.
Android O allows users to
select an autofill app,
similar to the way the
keyboard app is selected.
The autofill app is responsible
for storing and securing
user data, such as addresses,
credit card information, user
names, and even passwords.
There's also a new
view API that you
need to implement
in custom views
to ensure that
metadata is exposed
to the autofill framework.
Picture in picture is now
available for all devices, not
just Android TV.
All an app has to do is to call
enter picture in picture mode
method from the resumed
or paused state, where
the system supports
entering picture in picture.
Just like multi-window,
the activity
gets into paused state when
in picture in picture mode.
So if you have a media app,
make sure that the playback
continues in paused
state as well.
SetPictureinPictureArgs
allow activity
to specify the picture
in picture aspect
ratio, along with custom
remote actions that
allow the user to interact with
the picture in picture activity
directly.
Rather than having the app
explicitly use the presentation
API, regular
activities can now be
launched on secondary displays.
These displays have per
display based configuration
and resource management.
This means that some part
of the configuration,
such as screen width DP, screen
height DP layout, density DP,
will be set according to the
display on which the activity
currently resides.
Fonts are now a fully supported
resource type in Android.
You can use the getFont method
to get a font by its ID.
You can also define entire
font families in XML,
declaring the font
style and weight along
with the font resource.
There is much more in the
developer preview than this.
Please make sure to check
out the preview site
and learn more about O
and the preview program.
And check out the
Android developer channel
for more videos like these.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]